He's back or is he?
Welcome to Unfiltered. I'm S.E. Cupp.
The Donald Trump of 2016
who slayed more than a dozen GOP dragons
in the Republican primary
to become
the unlikely nominee for president
is hoping to make a comeback.
Looking for a repeat of 2016 In 2024
Trump appears
to be reverting to the old playbook,
swinging hard and early at his opponents.
We all remember the ugly punches
he threw,
many of which were unprecedented
in their nastiness,
trashing Carly Fiorina's face,
attacking Ted Cruz's
wife,
mocking little Marco Rubio's stature.
Questioning Ben Carson's faith,
Groh says it was it worked.
No one was able to match him in the ring.
His voters
seemed to revel
in the name calling,
while the rest of us cringed.
He'd carry the act into his presidency,
lashing out at opponents
both real and imaginary.
Getting in the gutter whenever possible.
Trump's act was novel back then.
But what about now?
More than six years later,
we've seen this show thousands of times
at rallies, on Twitter and truth social,
in interviews and on debate stages.
It isn't titillating or shocking now.
It's almost boring, in fact.
And his punches seem to have lost
some of their sting.
Back in November, Trump
tried out a new nickname
for Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis,
who is believed to be
considering a run for president.
Calling him Ron just sanctimonious.
At a Pennsylvania rally
sounding a little more
erudite than Trump's
usual schoolyard
taunts, the nickname hasn't stuck.
This week,
he called DeSantis a rhino globalist
for pushing vaccines
and COVID testing in Florida.
Somehow that doesn't seem
all that fatal either.
Trump's insisting
that DeSantis would be very disloyal
if you challenged him.
But a number of GOP
senators, from John Cornyn to John Thune,
Cynthia Lummis to Marco
Rubio have said no.
Anyone can run.
Former U.S. ambassador to the U.N.
Nikki Haley,
a onetime Trump
supporter, is also expected
to throw her hat in the ring.
Thus far, Trump had a light touch,
questioning her honor
while encouraging her
to try taking him on.
And he mocked his former vice
president, Mike Pence,
who is also mulling a run
for coming in at 7%
in a poll of hypothetical GOP
presidential contenders.
Oh, Mike is doing better than I thought.
He poked Mitt.
Sorry.
I know
we're just getting started,
but this Trump doesn't
seem to pack the punch
that 2016 Trump did
His fundraising numbers appear to agree.
He's brought in $9.5 million
in the six weeks
since he announced his bid
compared to the 11.8 million
he raised before the announcement.
Going in the wrong direction.
It's early but so far this Trump seems.
How should we say low energy.
Maybe he's lost his touch
as he's
faced one political storm after another.
Or maybe we've just been to see
the wizard
and we've seen behind the curtain.
And he isn't all that impressive anymore.
Only time will tell as more and more
Republicans get in the race and test
whether the Trump punch
has lost its sting.
That's it for me. See you next week.